the cozy jumper has returned as guys my
name is the chana welcome to another
cozy jumper video today I thought in the
game engine series we would do something
a little bit more fun than I was
intending to do because I've had a
pretty bad day I had deleted like a few
hours worth work in the livestream
accidently by like reverting the wrong
file so hasn't been good so instead of
diving into our game project and doing
some boring like project organization
moving this from the sandbox class into
its own game project showing you guys
how to set up a new game project and
Hazel I thought that I would save the
lovely fun tasks that Daddy is for
probably the next episode and today
let's take a look at something a little
bit more fun let's take a look at how
you can make little world a little map
inside this little game of Alice so just
a quick recap we have been working on
like a 2d top-down game here some kind
of RPG very loosely defined and last
time we added support for sub textures
or sprite shades check out that video if
you haven't already so today let's dive
in and take a look at how we can
basically use all of these sub textures
all these little various sprites that we
have within that one texture to
construct some kind of world now just a
just just just a word on this whole
process there are so many ways to do
this there are so many ways to craft a
world and it completely depends on what
it is you are trying to make if you have
a very like set vision in mind and you
know that for example you want you know
an island surrounded by water and you
want a path here and you want a tree
over there and you want this and that
then obviously you're going to want to
actually create that world yourself
however on the flip side is very common
to procedurally generate something and
that's definitely something that we'll
be doing at some point just because it's
very fun but it's not just fun it's just
a very very quick and efficient way to
generate a lot of content instead of
manually having to place everything
around the world you can actually just
you know write an algorithm that does
that for you and you can definitely
combine these two for example I can have
my base map my base layout defined by me
explicitly
and then have the trees or the different
like biomes will say just randomly
generate it on top of that that's
totally acceptable as well now going
down the route of doing
self which is what we're going to
attempt to do today it's it's not but
there's a lot of ways to do that as well
you could literally open up like a
little image file and pretend that each
pixel is a tile and then you can
literally draw that's one of my favorite
ways of doing this when I don't do that
today that we're gonna do something even
simpler what we're going to do is
literally open up a string here and
inside that string we're going to add a
bunch of characters to that string and
then each character is going to
correspond to a specific tile so that
way we can just basically draw it as in
like as an ASCII string and we don't
have to like open up a file or anything
like that this isn't my favorite way of
doing something like this as I mentioned
I think my favorite way of doing a kind
of tile based game level where it's
completely static and I know it's gonna
be a certain way is probably just like
as a very low resolution image file with
with each pixel mapping to each tile
just because it's very visual I can do
it as an external as an external file I
don't have to do it within the C++ code
but this is also totally valid and for
small games it might be just easier and
faster to do that so let's dive in and
take a look at how we can construct some
kind of world so last time with the
whole texture sub texture situation we
ended up with this so I'm just going to
close this and we're going to move on
from this point onwards the first thing
I want to do is actually take a look at
this image file and I guess we'll do
that in visual spheres really weird like
editor type thing which I still can't
get used to as you can see we have
certain tiles here that we actually want
to deal with so let's make a little map
here that maybe has a bunch of grass
around and maybe some of these some of
these like dirt tiles as well and of
course we need to have some kind of
transition between the tiles as well so
if this is the bottom left is 0 0 here
then 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 so 12 11
and then the 11 by one basically 11 X
and + 1 Y is going to be this kind of
centerpiece so that's what we're going
to deal with first
so just to test that out what I'll do is
from these coordinates I'll try
like I just mentioned and we'll see if
that barrel texture is now replaced with
that grass texture and you can see it is
not because I you know seem to get my X
and Y's around today so 11one11 is what
I meant I didn't even have to look back
at the image to realize my mistake it's
very silly okay beautiful so there it is
grass awesome
so with that grass in mind we know that
the one off to the left of it is going
to be slightly different so maybe let's
change the stairs to be 0 and then 11
and these are basically going to form
the building blocks of what we're going
to be able to do so if we add this one
you can see we now have a seamless kind
of transition between these two and it's
kind of beginning to look like a little
world now the camera is quite zoomed in
now I do probably still want to draw
them with the size of one by one I think
that will be our kind of tile size one
by one just because easier to deal with
so if we want to zoom out the camera
what we really just need to do is set
the zoom level of the camera to be
slightly more zoomed out so I think if I
just do camera set the zoom level I
don't even know what it is by default
but I think if I I think zooming out
zooming out make it like that i'ma go
smaller when we zoom out I don't
remember no I didn't think it did cuz
that that's not how projection really
works now what does zoom level actually
do sets the zoom level but it doesn't
recalculate anything does it okay so we
found a nice little bug type thing where
we probably want to recalculate the
bounds based on the zoom level so this
is as far as I can tell these two lines
of code are completely identical
so let's actually let's actually fix
this primer class a little bit let's
some will add a void called recalculates
review and recalculate view and if I was
called calculate view calculate view is
going to use the zoom level and the
aspect ratio all that stuff to actually
just do this basically so to calculate
the bounds and then set that projection
and for an orthographic camera again the
view and the projection is kind of tied
together just because our way of zooming
in is by just changing the projection
matrix so we'll change this to calculate
viewer and we'll do the same thing
and so this becomes a little bit more
simple and it also means that when we
set the zoom level like this since the
zoom level changes we can simply call
calculate review and so now if we do
something like this and again I still
don't know if we're zooming in the right
way here but we'll figure that out okay
so that if that does room in and then if
i zoom this out to like five now maybe
we will get something that looks a
little bit nicer okay that looks pretty
good to me so this is like an excepted
zoom level I think I'm not sure if it's
exactly a one-to-one pixel mapping we
can of course work that out but it looks
looks okay and it'll be good enough for
us for now so let's get onto this map
creation so what you can do is literally
make kind of a long string so if I type
in static comms chart because this
doesn't really like in fact we don't
really want a string we want a conch
chowder we'll call this s underscore map
tiles
I'll make this an array and then I will
are in fact where I need to make certain
rights a pointer let's hit equals here
and then we'll start actually making our
map so if I type in quotes like this I
can actually well I can type any text I
want in and the cool thing about C++ is
that if you type in another set of
quotes like this it will actually
concatenate these two strings for you so
this is this is one string it's
basically gone ahead and done this and
that's really cool and that's really
useful for situations like this
and in fact C++ in general deals with
strings like very well it's also like
this whole R thing that I really like
that allows you to do like whole
multi-line strings like this you know
and this is all kind of part of the
string here and you worry about new
lines it's it's great so I do like
simple splices string handling
capabilities okay
let's kind of think about this in a more
of a visual way so this is again why I
like that whole pixel kind of drawing
technique thing but if we bust out paint
here what I'm thinking is basically just
having like this kind of ocean island
thing we have is kind of you know this
is basically all water so we can easily
just make an infinite kind of water
terrain we're going to have to kind of
put the water inside these blocks but
then what I want is a bit of a shoreline
here
and then we just want dirt here maybe
trees like randomly scattered or
something like that that's kind of what
I'm going for here today so let's take a
look at how we would achieve something
like this I can easily just say that
zero is maybe our water and in fact you
don't really even need to specify water
because we could say that if if a block
doesn't exist then it's water but
obviously in this case we need to
actually define it in terms of a square
so maybe even if it is an out it will
look like that so that's - so that's 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18
19 20 21 22 23 24 through 24 so our map
will be twenty four tiles wide so now I
can just copy this and then paste it
over here that did not work as intended
and that's basically going to be my map
so we don't have to make it like it
doesn't have to be uniform or anything
like that let's just kind of do this for
now I don't really even need to know how
how big it is but we'll do something
like that
so now let's talk about what the
different tiles we might want are so
going back to our RPG pack so this tile
here is going to be like our grass tile
and this is going to be our dirt tile
now this one as we mentioned it was one
on the SS as 11 on the y-axis but we
probably want a bit of a transition with
water tiles so water tiles by the way we
0 is going to be a water tile here and
in fact if you wanted it to be up to
make a little bit more sense you could
easily just take these and like replace
them with w's so let's do that and I
hate Visual Studio fighting me here but
let's do that more tightly better way
I'll just replace 0 here with W okay and
that's a bit better let's tap these over
so with our water tiles in fact you know
what this might be better because this
way I don't think it's gonna find me if
I just make it over there okay so we
have a whole bunch of water tiles and
then let's maybe play around with dirt
so since I kind of want to have a
roundish kind of circular island then I
can start adding a little bit of a dirt
border here
now keep in mind that first of all you
know this has got to be a fairly rough
and second of all this is not going to
be perfect and third of all you know we
need to actually come up with some kind
of way to have more of like a I guess a
better transition between what is dirt
and what is water
okay I'm just gonna fill this in with
dirt here okay so now we have a bit of a
diamond shape here let's maybe add a
region here what we have some water
oops throughout the land maybe like uh
some kind of a lake or just to keep it
like that and that's it so important
things to keep in mind here the width
and height of this is kind of important
now you can definitely work out well
probably both of them but I mean more
realistically you can work out the
height we because obviously we can
figure out the length of the string so
it might be worth just adding something
here like static Const UN 32 T s map
width and we can set that to 24 just
because that's going to let us deal with
this a lot easier okay so if that's the
idea we have 24 as the map with then
let's figure out how we can actually
create tiles from this so the thing is
we don't really want to do any
transformation to the start if this data
is basically usable the way it is
because of course this is just just a
constant sharp pointer and I can't see
our pointer is essentially a bunch of
bytes each one of these characters is
one byte and since it is a one byte char
here one byte character which is
essentially just you know an integer we
can use that itself as like an index
into some kind of array to determine
what tile I actually want to render the
most efficient way probably to do
something like this would be to have
literally an array of these kind of sub
textures here where we have a sub
texture linked up to one of these
numbers because these are just numbers
and what you could do is you could
actually get the right character
subtract say a certain amount and then
you would have an array offset and you
could do that especially if you didn't
go with like W and D but maybe with zero
on one and all of that kind of stuff
then you could really have codes and you
wouldn't have to do anything now since
we don't really like performance is not
a huge issue for something like this
we're going to just use an unordered map
which is still a fairly efficient way of
doing this we're going to have HR code
here translate to a particular sub
texture 2d so that way we can just look
up that character code that that chart
that byte and then we'll see what
texture we need to use for that so let's
say this is our texture map and then we
obviously need to sprinkle a little bit
of hazel everywhere here and then going
back here what I'm going to do is load
in all of these sprites as I did so this
was the this was this grass right so we
don't actually have grass we're just
telling with dirt and water here so if
we go back to this let's see so if
that's one two three four five six I
think six so still eleven let's close
all this stuff it's still eleven but we
have six here so six is going to be out
dirt texture so what I'll do is I'll say
S texture map for dirt D I'm going to
set that equal to this right so now we
have a dirt texture and I'll probably
just maybe take this down a little bit
and then I'll do the same thing for W
for water except if that's 6 7 8 9 10 11
so 11 by 11 I think should be our water
texture so now we should have a very
rough map with no smooth transitions or
anything between the tiles of just dirt
and water so now when it comes time to
render this all we really need to do is
write a little bit of a for loop so I
will do this
I guess lot of juice here so it will say
for you int 32 and you can do this any
in this a number of ways but we'll just
kind of do it in a way that in in a way
that makes sense I think the most so for
y equals 0 Y is less than now we need to
know what the height is so I
deliberately didn't write that but we do
still need to know what the map height
is so I think what I might do is over
here I might do M map with M map PI's
and then what we'll do is we'll assign
over here where we do all of this stuff
we will assign map width to be the s map
width and in the height so we could
calculate
just saying map height equals sterling
which is the length of that map with
sorry of that map tiles string and then
/ of course the map width so now we
should have the map height this is just
a bit of a easier kind of process I
guess and I was having to just make a
variable called map height and then
count all these and then if we added
more we'd have to compensate so yeah
we'll just we'll do it this way it'll be
a little bit easier okay so we have the
map with the map hive so now if we
iterate through all of that so map
height y plus plus and then we're also
notice we're also iterating through the
well the inner loop is the X loop that's
because we want to try and read our
memory like moral more along the lines
of how it's actually laid out in memory
so we don't want to be jumping like this
because that's not going to be great for
our CPU cache usage like I mean what
this is not much data realistically but
I still don't think it'll all fit into
one cache line anyway the point is if
you write your loop this way around it's
actually going to be faster than if you
write it the other way around so just
keep that in mind okay cool so because
if we write it this way around it goes
without saying that every single byte
that we access here is like the next
byte in memory all the way until we
finish iterating through the whole map
okay so now we just need to basically
look up the texture map and sorry the
texture map is not the map tiles which
is what I was thinking of we need to
look up the map tiles so we have
basically an x and a y coordinates we
can do X plus y times map width which
will get us the appropriate like memory
offset because remember like we are we
like to deal with this as a 2d kind of
map as if it's like a 2d array but it's
- it's still not it's just one
contiguous block of memory and that's
faster than having a 2d array of course
where you have like a lot of memory
indirection so s texture map is what
we're trying to look up this is the key
so this is our character so we can say
char tile type equals that and then we
can say s texture map tile type that
should be our texture now it's possible
that it doesn't exist so you what you
could do
is you could say if s texture map dot
finds tile type doesn't equal s texture
map dot and right then you can actually
find the right thing so this would just
be like a way for us to render some kind
of extra like arrow texture if it
doesn't find the right thing so if we
look over here we could just have like a
little bit of a safety net let's just
say that we render well we can just
render the barrel or something like that
if it does not find the right texture so
what I'll do is over here I'll write ref
sub texture 2d texture right and then
we'll and we'll just use hazel here as
well and then what we'll do is if if
this actually equals the end right then
all will say if it doesn't equal the end
we'll assign texture to be our our
texture map tile type otherwise we will
assign texture to be one of the textures
that we had so maybe like the barrel so
if you get the barrel then you're using
an invalid tile type okay cool
so what's next I think we actually okay
so we actually need to render this
obviously so let's do hazel render a 2d
draw quad and then we'll do we'll draw
it it there that's fine and then one by
one and in the texture is just gonna be
texture and I think that's it okay so we
should get a map here with hi to
everything else and hit f5 okay so we
did get a map technically it's just that
unfortunately I forgot to actually
position it so we're just printing it
all at the origin we don't want to do
that we want to actually move it around
so since the size is one by one all I
really have to do is just say X Y and
then I'm done however I want it to be
centered around the middle and this is
where obviously if you had like a player
in this map you just set the players
position and that would offset the whole
map but since we're not in a position to
do that I'm actually going to just write
X minus M map with / - right so what
we're doing here and we'll do the same
thing with map highs what we're doing
here is just offsetting everything by
half of
it's width and height which should mean
that we're drawing everything a little
bit offset so now let's launch this and
see what we get all right cool and there
is our beautiful looking map that looks
very kind of squished in kind of looks
like a fish there you go
okay so thoughts about this I mean first
of all it's great obviously we have a
way to render a little map and we can
kind of draw out whatever we want if we
use an invalid character like a C then
we should get a barrel looks like we
actually get a crash though so that's
not exactly what I was expecting what
happened here with attack of the Tetris
empty what what's wrong with our barrel
texture did we delete that no that's the
one that we happen to use okay let's get
the stairs instead barrel texture is
null so that's why we should fix that
though if we sit obviously if we try and
draw a quad with a null texture then we
should just like I don't know maybe a
third or something all right that's not
exactly the stairs but it looks like we
get this weird texture in that place I
think it's also worth noting that
everything is upside-down and that's
because of the way that we render
everything obviously we of course want
to read it from top to bottom but OpenGL
and the way that our renderer is set up
right now reads it from here to here
which also is like fine but just a
consideration you have to make if you
want to flip it you can of course flip
it you can just reverse this whole thing
if I go over here to the position and
write map height - all of this then it's
going to result in a flip and you can
see I now get the fish and the right way
around so that is what you can do if you
would like a quick and dirty way of kind
of putting a map together I probably
wouldn't do it this way just because
it's a little bit tedious and of course
I could spend a lot of time on this and
make it look beautiful like a place a
bunch of trees around it's fairly easy
to detect when we transition from a
water tile to a dirt tile we just need
to check the neighboring tile and in
that case what we could do is for
example change one of those dirt tiles
or change the dirt tile that is kind of
participating in a tile transition to be
one of the kind of you know Shores or
one of the transition tiles from that
sprite sheet in fact if
you guys want to see that maybe we could
do that next time I don't know drop a
comment below but likely what we're
going to do is maybe next time if we
refactor the project and do all that
stuff because we needed we really need
to get that stuff done but in general
what I want to do is also kind of use
the drawing technique that we can just
you know read in like an image file and
then see what the pixels are and all
that stuff
but then also procedurally generating
this would also be a lot faster and
easier but I think you guys get the
point
optimizations white like this is fairly
fast like you really reading the map
data is lightning fast here there's
really nothing you could do I think in
that regard the only thing that you
could do potentially is combine the
geometry together so at the moment
obviously each one of these quads like
each one like all of these quads are
being drawn individually like yes it is
bashed together into one draw but you're
still like dealing with quite a bit of
geometry right because if you look at
this I mean really what we could do is
just say that well this is an
uninterrupted block this is an
uninterrupted block of dirt so what we
could do is just basically combine those
vertices together and draw them as one
kind of mesh that's again something that
you could do if you really want it to I
to be honest with 2d rendering like that
it's not something that I see very often
because there's never there's not like a
third dimension of potential occlusion
you're always rendering everything that
you are seeing in a game like Minecraft
for example where you have like you know
a lot of blocks underneath the surface
that you definitely don't want to render
because there's so many of them and
they're gonna make everything crazy well
yeah you would combine your mesh into
just like a visible outline mesh
basically of what the outside of what
the camera can see from the outside but
in this like you're basically you
basically already done that so it's not
really an optimization I think that
needs to be made anyway I hope you guys
enjoy this video if you did please hit
the like button let me know your
thoughts with what you offer have a way
to make this all maps together ahh I do
want to still show thee as I mentioned
the whole drawing a map thing in paint
and then also I want to probably deal
with the kind of tiled transitions
anyway hope you guys enjoy this video as
I mentioned don't forget that you can't
help
bought this series on patreon patron
confers Lana Turner the live streaming
which I delivered was today so you can
you can jump on that and take a look at
at how amazing that moment was thank you
all for watching I will see you next
time goodbye
[Music]
you
[Music]